The martyr doesn't seem to want to see you, so
could you please go home? Isn't it the Saga that makes you not want to go home when you're told to go home?
Or is it like fighting a mule?
Heisei Let's do it proudly where we want
4 It
's possible to go there
[Applause]
Heater Human May You should regret the railroad from breaking tiles
Advanced level first is terrible power
ana
[music]
Ho Result 1
Correction Odanishi  Didn't I tell you that I'd go ahead and do it?
On
the 2nd floor of the village, there's no marker holding plate,
or rather, I can't drink this.
Hm, what is this?
That power is still stupid, even the previous evil is far away Look at
that power and give it to me I wonder
if it's okay to use recovery magic on the horse tribe
Maybe
it's okay Cutter
Repeat 4
[music]